Pergunta que eu recebi, existe mesmo
essa janela de oportunidade sobre a
reposição hormonal? Seria em torno de 10
anos? Olha só, vamos falar aqui sobre um
assunto super importante.
Essa é uma coisa que muita gente tem
dúvida, a tal da janela de oportunidade
da reposição hormonal. Sabe quando você
tá lá na faixa dos 50 e poucos anos e
começa a ter calorões que parece que
alguém ligou um forno dentro de você?
Pois é, minha gente. É sobre isso que a
gente vai conversar. Imagine comigo a
seguinte situação. Você tem uma amiga,
vamos chamar ela de Maria. A Maria tem
52 anos, parou de menstruar faz 2 anos e
tá sofrendo com aqueles fogachos
terríveis. Ela ouve falar sobre
reposição hormonal, mas fic com mil
dúvidas, será que ainda dá tempo? Será
que é seguro? E aí que entra essa
história da janela de oportunidade que
eu vou falar com vocês agora. A ciência
descobriu uma coisa fascinante, gente.
Nosso corpo tem um timing perfeito para
começar a reposição hormonal. É como se
fosse aquele momento ideal para plantar
uma semente. Se você planta na época
certa, a árvore cresce forte, saudável.
Se deixa passar muito tempo, aí
complica. Essa janela mágica são os
primeiros 10 anos após a menopausa ou
antes dos 60. Simples assim. Mas por que
que esses benditos 10 anos são tão
importantes? Eu vou contar.
Quando a mulher tá na menopausa, o
estrogênio, aquele hormônio maravilhoso
que a gente produz durante toda a vida,
fértil, começa a dar tchau e o nosso
corpo, coitado, fica meio perdido sem
ele. Os vasos sanguíneos, o coração, os
ossos, todo mundo sente falta desse
hormônio. Agora aqui vem o pulo do gato.
Se você repõe o hormônio logo no
comecinho, quando o corpo ainda tá
fresquinho da perda, ele aceita numa
boa. É como se os receptores hormonais
ainda estivessem ali esperando
ansiosamente pelo estrogênio voltar. Mas
se você deixa passar muito tempo, aí é
outra história. Depois de 10 anos sem
hormônio, já não é a mesma coisa. Nossos
vasos sanguíneos já mudaram, ficaram
mais durinhos, menos flexíveis. É como
tentar dobrar um galho seco, pode até
quebrar, não é? Por isso que começar a
reposição depois desse período pode, em
alguns casos, aumentar riscos. Isso é
contraditório, mas existe estudos
falando que pode aumentar risco pro
coração e pra circulação. Eu
particularmente não concordo muito com
isso. Os estudos mais recentes,
incluindo as diretrizes da Febrasgo de
2024, mostram que mulheres que começam a
terapia hormonal dentro dessa janela de
10 anos tem benefícios incríveis. Não é
só acabar com os calorões, não. Estamos
falando da proteção cardiovascular,
prevenção de osteoporose, melhora do
sono, da disposição da pele, prevenção
de Alzheimer. É um pacote completo de
qualidade de vida. Mas calma lá, não é
só chegar na farmácia e comprar
hormônio, não. Cada mulher é única, tem
a sua história, suas condições de saúde.
Por isso, avaliação médica
individualizada é fundamental. Tem
mulher que pode usar tranquilamente, tem
outras que precisam de cuidados
especiais e outras que têm até que ter
contraindedicação. E olha que
interessante, para quem não sabe
exatamente quando entrou na menopausa,
porque, né, às vezes a gente nem lembra
o que comeu ontem, imagina lembrar
quando foi a última menstruação. A regra
é simples, até os 60 anos a janela
provavelmente ainda tá aberta. Agora,
uma coisa importante que eu preciso
falar, não existe prazo de validade para
parar a reposição. Antigamente tinha
aquela história de, ah, usa 5 anos e
para. Hoje a gente sabe que não é assim.
Quantos benefícios superem os riscos, a
mulher também tá sentindo bem, ela deve
continuar. é uma decisão que se toma
junto com o médico reavaliando
periodicamente. Mas olha, tem uma
polêmica que eu preciso compartilhar com
vocês. Alguns médicos da medicina
funcional, como é o meu caso, tem
questionado essa regra rígida dos 10
anos. E sabe por quê? Porque mesmo após
esse período, a reposição hormonal pode
trazer benefícios importantes pra saúde
óssea, muscular e cerebral.
É como se o corpo ainda pudesse
aproveitar alguns benefícios do
hormônio, mesmo que os vasos sanguíneos
já não respondam tão bem quanto antes. A
questão é que os benefícios
cardiovasculares realmente diminuem, mas
outros sistemas do corpo podem continuar
a se beneficiar. Pensa comigo, nossos
ossos, músculos e cérebro t receptores
de estrogênio que continuam funcionando
mesmo depois de anos sem hormônio.
Quando repomos mesmo tardiamente,
podemos melhorar a densidade óssea,
prevenir fratura, manter a massa
muscular fundamental para evitar quedas
e manter a independência e até proteger
funções cognitivas. É claro que a
decisão precisa ser super
individualizada, avaliando cada caso com
muito cuidado. Uma mulher de 65 anos
saudável com osteoporose e sem fatores
de risco cardiovascular pode sim se
beneficiar da reposição, mesmo estando
fora da janela tradicional. O segredo é
usar doses baixas, preferencialmente
pela via transdâmica, e fazer
acompanhamento rigoroso. Não é decisão
simples, mas também não é um nunca mais
absoluto. Então, voltando pra nossa
amiga Maria lá do começo, com 52 anos e
apenas 2 anos de menopausa, ela tá no
timing perfeito. A janela de
oportunidade dela tá escancarada. Então,
se ela decidir fazer a reposição com
acompanhamento médico adequado, a chan
de ter uma qualidade de vida muito
melhor são enormes. O recado que fica é
esse. A janela de oportunidade existe
sim, é real, é comprovada
cientificamente. São os primeiros 10
anos após a menopausa ou antes dos 60.
Passado esse período não significa
acabou tudo, mas os riscos aumentam pelo
menos por alguns estudos e os benefícios
teoricamente diminuem. É como diz o
ditado, tempo é dinheiro e no caso da
reposição hormonal, tempo é saúde.
Espero que essa conversa tenha
esclarecido suas dúvidas sobre esse tema
tão importante. E lembra, conhecimento é
poder e quanto mais a gente entende
sobre o nosso corpo, melhores decisões a
gente toma. Até a próxima, pessoal.
Yeah.